we've been helped
don't you remember critic it's me Tamra
oh yeah
from the Catwoman review yeah yeah
you're you're funny in that thank you
I find you socially awkward due to
you're disturbing silence I see that you
have the Wicker Man DVD in your
possession oh yeah did you know that
that's my favorite movie I don't even
know what your last name is why would I
know that do you have the original or
the Unrated version the Unrated oh good
why no reason
enjoy your movie oh thanks say what what
sweep ah fuck
keep going that way please Jesus what's
going on around ah will you get out of
here please down run around it miss ah
yeah here you little whack-a-mole
is it this we couldn't get any more
creepy let's keep it going with Nicolas
Cage
I actually have a confession to make I'm
actually not Nicolas Cage I'm Nicolas
Cage pretending to be an airway that he
sounds like Nicolas Cage is he fucked up
by anyway I'm gonna be starring in about
26 other movies this month and if they
ever made a live-action we need to poo I
play
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to let's
talk about Neela Butte you might not
recognize his name but you might
recognize his movies Lakeview Terrace
nurse Betty and probably his most
controversial in the company of men and
if you were like most movie goers this
was probably your reaction to them his
films usually had a shockingly harsh
mean-spirited tone that many critics
like but most audiences didn't know how
to accept we take a girl at a time
just some corn-fed bitch then one day
out goes a rug and us pulling it hard
she'll be reaching for the sleeping
pills within a week and we will laugh
about this - we are very old men people
came out of each film saying it is piss
my pants uncomfortable which i think is
the film's intent but is the film
actually any good I think so
wish it's saying something ish that I
think is beneficial ish for years and
years nobody quite knew what to make of
it that is until the abominable remake
that finally gave moviegoers clarity
that being that I loved all his films we
know that quite clearly this one is
absolute shit then remake is of course
wicker man
based on the British cold head of the
70s the film centers around a cop
brought in to investigate an abduction
on an island ran by a bizarre cult the
major change in this one the island is
dominated by women yeah interesting
change but die sure him a guy who wrote
a story about sexist men breaking the
heart of a lonely depressed deaf woman
will clearly show no signs of misogyny
here but why wait to find out let's take
a look at the burning disaster remake
that is wicker man so it's the credits
roll we naturally open up with our hero
played by Nicolas Cage he's a cop who
likes checking out books I'm sure most
of us will need to read after viewing
this picture he's off doing his complete
duties when he sees a kid drop her doll
out the window she says I didn't think
you can make Nicolas Cage grabbing a
girl's doll actually look cool but my
god this movie actually kind of pulled
it off and the name uh strawberry
shortcake you shall be avenged so he
pulls the car over to get the child back
her doll great thanks a lot we stopped
silence I'm so sorry she's belted in
don't worry
comes with the territory I'll get it has
an officer it's my duty to keep my eyes
peeled for any opportunity to serve and
protect
except of course when the giant truck is
traveling on the wrong side of the road
for no reason plunging is and civilians
into a fiery ditch four summaries I'm
not very good at spotting goes
cage tries to save them but the little
girl is too busy being needlessly creepy
because that's what kids at movies kind
of did for a while and she burns up in
the fight cut to some time later they
never specifically say how long as the
scenes Cage has a problem getting over
his mistake hey son and that sums it up
so um you got a scene for me
stop helping you you don't understand I
don't really need this well she added a
lot as we see cage gets a letter from
his ex-fiance who apparently has elvish
penmanship and alerts him that not only
has she moved to an island called summer
Isle not only does she have a child
named Rowan not only is she probably his
not only is she now missing it she's
incredibly concerned but she wants him
to come to the island and look for her
god damn
that's like Jesus finally writing to his
father saying how he enjoyed Jerusalem
hey hey so he goes to his cop friend to
try and get some advice who quite
frankly seems way too spontaneously into
this having just heard about it the plot
thickens so is this like some old
girlfriend or something this sir willow
we were engaged sounds like she got kind
of close with someone else two summers
Isle she's got the nerve to contact you
now shit I mean you're gonna blow this
off right why don't you do a little
digging on her first I mean come on tell
her to contact the father give her a
call I don't know why I'm just really
upset about your problems right now Oh
Oh your husband's been murdered we'll be
lucky to you we need to be in that
briefing in 10 minutes okay hey it's
good to see you yeah still got no same
for me okay nevertheless Kage agrees to
the cases when travelling to the island
he can't help but still think of the
girl he let down before
Jesus Christ to let the truck on the
boat do boats really need a sign that
says no trucks allowed if it's a party
boat do we have to put no trucks under
21 allowed holy fuck this movies
dramatic subtlety is on par with you a
jack so he gets to the island of summer
Isle or as I like to call it the creepy
Shire if he comes across some scary
Hobbit folk now complaint has been made
by a resident of this island ain't you
saying yes ma'am about a missing child
oh no that's always trouble what's in
the bag a shark or something go on take
a peek
well nothing suspicious here you go
ahead and take your bleeding moving
human-sized bag to wherever while you
laugh maniacally I'm gonna go see if
this place has any cake so he wants into
the middle of the hocus-pocus two
auditions to see if he can get any
answers are you the barman here wherever
you call I'm sister Beach yes what's her
name again I'm sister Beach yes please
tell me that's the only time we hear
that name is Beach mr. Beach sister big
sister Beach
hey there's not enough images of
slaughtered bunnies in the world to get
me not to laugh at that sister Beach my
brethren will get revenge in the okiya
smoke over the top way possible sorry
I'm allergic so he comes across as
ex-fiance named willow who is quite the
talent for giving all information and no
information at the same time what in the
hell happened to you
we were young so what why do we do
anything I need some Cayenne sir I was
scared why do this we're different here
was it some other guy I wasn't ready for
this okay if I give you a multiple
choice between a B and C will you give
me a straight answer that she's keen
Christ speaking of which
eh continues to see all sorts of
strangeness on the island twins talking
in unison women wearing red hoods over
their heads everybody talking in scary
foreshadowing tones leelee sobieski and
oddly enough decides not to get the fuck
out of there but again being caged maybe
this all makes him feel at home
excuse me did something unpack my bag
because I'm missing some tapes I
wouldn't know about that
they're called everything's okay then
Missy goes that nervous
things don't get any better when he
continues to dream about the same girl
he lost before again this thing follows
his subconscious like Freddy Krueger
driving the truck from dual it doesn't
get any scarier the more you show it it
just gets funnier did we just get a loop
of that and they say there's nothing get
out of here a cage thinks he sees rowing
in the garden and tries to go after her
thinking he's narrowed her down in the
bar Rowan
I could hear your Rouge which is running
obnoxious when you think about it how
come in a movie whenever somebody passes
the camera in the dark it's always
accompanied by a rush I mean do people
have no control over that it's really
annoying
ah Malcolm huh can you keep your ruche
down I'm just talking about how
obnoxious it is sorry
it's the new shoes he loses track of her
and doesn't seem to get any closer
making this scene entirely pointless he
does however note is what any fucking
idiot would notice the first time being
there a massive lineup of pictured girls
all looking like they're about to be
sacrificed at an altar but one picture
seems to be missing our harvest festival
we have one the end of each autumn and
then the festival of fertility too of
course we have in the last year's afraid
it got ruined last night okay let's cut
the bullshit we all know you're Brian
Cox and drag just stop pretending so it
goes to see if he can get any answers
from little Lele hey I meant to ask you
in there do you recognize this girl
where's the other woman who works here
no let's go back to the question you
just asked and clearly didn't get an
answer - have you seen this little girl
God do you have any policeman in sight
would you do this on any other case
excuse me have you seen this white man
with glasses and a goatee okay well
that's good enough for me alright guys
nothing to see here
things get imagine this even stranger
when he goes to a school that only seems
to be teaching girls will you tell us
what man represents in his purest form
yes Alex in both Alex and hi-hi-hi as a
man I am very offended I mean as opposed
to just say it
schools really changed since I was a kid
how dare you stand there and frighten my
children Wow
Nicolas Cage is so creepy he can scare
people by just standing in the same room
as them don't let's be honest none of us
are surprised by that whose desk is this
my apologies
we are studying the textbook of lazy
jump-scares ok chapter 2 children
walking by the camera and going through
more questions he asks of course the
fewer answers he gets if Rowan Woodward
existed if I suppose her mother is lying
to me - huh not lying no grieving you
mean that Rowan is dead it was an
accident what kind of accident leave
things alone
please sister Rose how'd she die she'll
burn to death what'd you just say
she burned to death so seeing how Rowan
has more inconsistent backstories than
Tommy Wiseau Kate sets out at least to
locate the body or grave which neither
willow nor cage thinks proves at all
that she's actually dead they put it
there I didn't who's that so here's a
crazy idea he asked her to take into the
place where she last saw her uh
shouldn't this have been the first
frigging thing that he did so this where
you last saw wrong mm-hmm yeah
can you give me the details it's
important sorry I don't operate in
details just for shadowing bullshit that
makes for great creepy padding and
you're sure it's no way it could be
someone from off the island no well that
could be considered a clue if it wasn't
typical writing for any child stuck at
school waiting for me so he doesn't seem
to get any closer that is until he
thinks he sees her drowning under the
duck
Oh clearly it was just a dream
he wasn't oh my god no just a dream god
damn it
a double fake out really we're that
desperate yeah
the Lisa cock done is at least thrown in
another truck so he goes to ask more
questions after randomly passing by the
cult of Jawas as he just now
fucking realizes that Rowan was the girl
missing in the framed picture no you
think why don't you tell me Rome was a
part of all this ah the rituals
well I'm frightened at this place too
all right I'm sorry
doesn't matter matter Jesus Christ does
this guy ever use his brain these have
got to be some of the worst detective
skills of all time I mean how stupid you
have to be
how's the review coming critic that's
him listen here you creepy will Elf on a
shelf I'm not gonna let a crazy a
potentially dangerous person get in the
way of my work what are you gonna do
leave call for backup bring in as many
sane and rational people possible to
level out this insane playing field
no maybe unbelievably stupid I'm just
gonna ask obvious question after obvious
question that anyone would know in the
hopes that you will give me an
incredibly vague answer that'll make me
more angry oh all right then go ahead
what's going on here they would know who
is very days then Bennett Bay all is
knowing knowing is all you can't
understand that not understanding is
understanding when you can't understand
understand your fakeness is meant to be
all right then maybe I should leave fine
I think I've utilized my detective
skills long enough dad here
whoo okay so after that
we get out of here
it's a bad day to be me
you
so in keeping with his brilliant
deduction skills kate gets absolutely no
answers from anybody so he tours the
island more he notices that the men on
the island are only used for labour and
are never allowed to speak kind of like
how they treat people at ward but Rumble
starts at Bruin when he comes across a
giant farm of bees as you remember cage
is horribly allergic to bees
so what to do run deeper into the farm
of bees of course because it's opposite
day he gets stoned too many times and
passes out but is saved by some of the
workers who dropped him off as sister
Summer Isles home the woman who runs the
island played by Ellen Burstyn think of
walking just outside the beehives which
cage seems to be taking miraculously
well seeing how he nearly died from them
I piss my pants if I saw one on a
sandwich after that so she talked about
how they honor the great goddess and
also their treatment of men on the
island men are what second-class
citizens no not at all we love our men
we're just not subservient to them my
men are a very important part of our
little colony breathing you know my god
this island is terrible all the men do
around here is mate and stay at home and
mate and not have to talk to anybody and
mate and can I have a cage in here the
strongest finest the most sturdy of our
kind female right well well the upper
body strength Barry comes to help you
move a recliner then we'll talk
but then cage remembers oh yeah a little
girl thing and brings the questions back
to looking for her perhaps it is time
for you to stop bullshitting me okay be
careful especially when a little girl's
life is at stake my little girl I'm sure
you've guessed as a matter of fact yes
I'm only interested in the law ah how do
I have permission to open the grave of
Rowan Woodward oh listen the impression
I've already given it tale so he gets
permission to look through the grave but
all he finds is a Brent little doll this
of course gets caged even angry are this
verse tell me yeah how'd it get fine how
did you burn
to burn how to get burn somebody lit it
somebody lit it where are you going
doctor her place and I'm coming with you
no willow I mean it maybe if we
something bad is about to happen I can
feel it yes because everything's been
going great up until now I'd hate to see
what happens if this all went down some
weird nonsensical Road
like that's a good start let's see
what's behind door number two though
is it weird B thing o'clock already and
folks that's only the beginning of where
this Tijuana car wash of insanity takes
you including the great gonzo being
pulled over by cage at gunpoint get off
the bike step away from the bike I have
shot people over less than that hey
guess who I am
Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada that's
right Monica Crawley it is II huh
so that's why the Olsen twins don't make
public appearances anymore who you were
playing why the hell will we be laughing
except to create and that's a creepy
environment because the amping and
storytelling can't deliver on its own
now with a take home edition and now
we've entered a kegger in Narnia but
instead of Aslan leading the party we
have Oh Oh goddess of the fields please
accept our offering we may be able to
take this off our layers in a but we'll
never be able to take it off our
embarrassing IMDB page and yes it looks
like cage has finally had enough of this
goddamn motherfucking island time to
punch a beach in the mouth I swear
making me think you were Albert Finney
but little Lili attacks and yes they
actually do have a fight sequence
together all while Carol lot is getting
smashed
you know for the stronger sex Island you
could teach less wimpy fighting lives
yeah fear me I am mighty God well looks
like sobieski needs to sober up ski so
he disguises himself in a bear zoom mrs.
Beach was gonna wear and he works his
way into the light parade he'll bury me
get me out of here ha ha ha no serious
we're all big trouble I told you away
from me
you mean nothing had to go so Kage
finally finds Rowan who's about to be
sacrificed and decides to save the day
and one of the most surreal
unintentionally funny moments ever put
to Phil what is it what's wrong sister
what is it what's wrong sister
hey pretty what are you looking at
family pictures know all my old Berra
jokes I've made so many in the past now
look at this one this is when
Christopher Walken said it's not over
bears he never says anything like a
human all one here this is from Care
Bears too when dark hearts said time for
a game of disappearing bears he never
says anything natural either oh and
there's child and has been talking about
hunting bears
there's even Sean Connery in a bear suit
wow so many bear memories and yet here
Malcolm here in Wicker Man is the holy
grail of bear scenes a moment where
Nicholas Cage is in a bear suit and he
punches out a woman while Ellen
Braveheart watches ah there's just so
many jokes I can do and I don't know
which one to pick
maybe I should just get the joke all
together hey don't talk like that
you know sometimes the more obvious the
joke the more it has to be addressed
but which one should I do which one
should I do tell you what why don't you
do all of them
all of them yes that way the public can
decide which one's best you know that's
not such a bad idea Thank You Malcolm
thank you for understanding my bear
dilemma it's what I'm here for
is it working yes everything is going
according to plan
okay so here are my Nicolas Cage bear
jokes walk a walk a whore Papa Bear says
this bitch is too conscious Bernstein
family says hi allow me to introduce
myself I'm Winnie the shuffle the bear
necessities will like you to get more
acquainted with the ground gummy bears
bones in here and there and in your face
sister Rose me brother bear I hear
you've been harnessing picking at
baskets Paddington told me we should
meet praise to fair can't get enough of
that golden Chris bears got the crunch
with and the number one Nicolas Cage
bear joke is hollow you can prevent not
getting your ass kicked by Nicolas Cage
play me on Paul
so Kate saves Rouen but little does he
know she was never in any danger at all
in fact she even runs back to her group
who welcomed her with open arms
you have come of your own free will to
keep this appointment with the wicker
man and now the game is over the game of
the hunter leading the hunter this was
all part of the new reality show called
fucking McKay next week we're gonna see
what happens if we make him think he's a
vampire back cage tries to fight them
off but what do you know no more bullets
they break his legs taken to a giant
wicker man and put him inside setting it
ablaze worst Burning Man ever but it
doesn't stop there we get one more
ending where I swear to God James Franco
and Jason Ritter are off-duty cops in a
bar chatting it up check it out huh hey
you want to hear about a role where I
destroy a world's entire future by my
mere existence Planet of the Apes No
oh the green powerful well hello there
but then sister willow enters in and
presumably it all starts over again when
you leave here where are you coming it's
my apartment when you do will you take
me with you
gosh you betcha and that was wicker man
what the fuck I think it's trying to be
anti-feminist but on the other hand cage
is kind of a shouting idiotic jerk as
are happy other guys in the movies so
maybe it's the other way around showing
that being chauvinistic and misogynistic
will lead to your demise but then why do
they try to make this place come out so
creepy and insane
I don't know and in the end I don't care
because it's incredibly obvious this is
a giant piece of shit I mean this flick
is so entertaining ly bad and every
other second has something to laugh at
in terms of how awkward it is so if
you're looking for a batshit insane
movie that will have you unintentionally
laughing in the aisles
then this wicker ham is for you I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to
you
the isn't that usual yet not quite
aren't you forgetting something critic
Tamra the hell are you doing here the
review is over
there's one famous part you forgot to
mention the most famous part of the
movie and my all-time favorite scene not
the no be no goddamnit
everybody talks about that stupid scene
the Internet has talked about this
stupid scene since the beginning a
stupid scene we are not talking about
that stupid scene I'm talking about this
- Missy you're not talking about a
stupid scene you're not talking about
that stupid scene - we're not talking
about my stuff I'd say I thought you'd
say that which is why we've come to make
sure that you follow through over four
million hits on YouTube countless quotes
in countless forums it cannot be ignored
it is your destiny no the more I miss
the joke the Lord has to be addressed
no the more obvious the joke the Lord
has to be addressed what you think
saying then unison is some how can I
change my mind no but this will
reference the beads
yeah
never
see you in hell you fucking fucker
oh yeah rice bags without the rest of
the lollipop yeah like that hello
what is that no no not that
anything but that no no no not the means
not to be oh they're everywhere but
they're all over the Internet
oh they're in my eyes I've seen them so
much they're ingrained in my eye
all right oh right I'm sorry Papa fun to
be riced
the irony is that the most famous scene
in this movie where cage is being
tortured by the bees isn't even in the
original it was in the Unrated cut so
this moment literally is so enjoyed that
it became popular despite it never
getting a theatrical release so what is
it about this moment that everybody goes
nuts for is it the bees are so horribly
CG is it that the idea itself is so
crazy is it that he keeps shouting
they're in my eyes when they're clearly
not in his eyes well the only conclusion
I can come to why everybody loves this
scene of course is the cage man himself
it's only a few seconds long but he does
his thing screaming at the top of his
lungs asking what something is like
they're honestly gonna tell him what is
it what is it and even shaking his head
back and forth going
ah perhaps just because it's not just
typical over-the-top well okay it kind
of is but it's also just kind of awkward
he's not going full cage freak out this
is more like an eight or a nine if he
was his eyes would be more bulky like
they usually are he just sort of goes
half way and then kind of gives up which
bizarrely enough makes it even more
over-the-top and strange perhaps it's
one of those instances we're going big
but not all the way big makes it even
more awkward and memorable and
surprisingly maybe making it the biggest
moment in any cage movie it has its own
unique blend of strange not of this
world so bad it's good corniness that
will live on in ridiculous film history
oh no not the Bears
not the bears there you happy appraisee
obsessed fuck oh I am I am
wait but the hell you going don't you
understand critic the journey never ends
I must find other Nicolas Cage fans to
talk about the scene so that it may be
exploited for all of eternity
okay we were having a meeting about this
tomorrow
she was very persuasive now know best
Nicolas Cage movie ever Bad Lieutenant
Board of called New Orleans you out of
your mind because it's the John classic
face off why because you've got Nicolas
Cage wielding twin gold-plated desert
eagles he was doing that in his own mind
in Bad Lieutenant plus with dancing
souls iguanas and fat val kilmer
eh I could eat a peach for hours but be
that as it may I hear you two are
Nicolas Cage fans it's a touch bit of an
understatement honestly would that mean
that you would be interested in maybe
doing a a wicker man review the future
possibly for little old me duh what the
hell okay
Arya Stark if you think you can just
leave after all the crazy shit you put
me through you got another thing coming
you are by far the craziest the nastiest
meanest sadistic desist I gotta get this
distance criminally insane unwell
mentally ill fucking obsessed not John
I've ever seen in my entire life and I
am gonna do what needs to be done about
it
your can work for me my views only seem
to go up whenever I'm in pain yeah sure
hey can't you read no trucks under 21
yeah I'm pretty sure that was a 2012
Silverado how'd it get burned how to get
burn